I feel as sad looking at this guy turn into like a gay loser
as I do seeing not so aridite wear the zooies choker. Dude, this
is horrific. I these people should be in town square. >> Not
not until dead just in terms of like they should be in like a
gibbit or something. A gibbit. Okay. A gibbit. >> Should
be should be locked away forever.
What's up? How's it going? Oh, hey. >> We're watching the
We're watching the
>> Yeah. Uh Oh, wait. No, I'm not on Twitch anymore. Yeah.
Yeah, we were watching her cry like the whole clip of her crying
about not banking money. >> She crying.
>> Oh, you haven't seen any of this?
>> Okay. Um, her buddy like comes in. She like does a shill
for money. Okay. and her buddy basically comes in and is like,
"Why do you beg for money? It's so cringe."
And
he kind of just gets like totally rattled by it. I think he I
think they have a dynamic where they each other. I think he just
got he just got totally rattled and like started crying and talking
about how much she hates streaming. And >> aren't they
on the left? Isn't like having a GoFundMe like the primary way
to make money if you're like >> Yeah, but she's literally
running a GoFundMe cuz she's getting sued by Ethan Klein. So,
she probably feels weird about starting two go like she can't
have nested GoFundMes. >> Oh, that's pretty funny. >> Hold
on. Hold on. Let me I'll see if I can find the clip. >> If
she prays to Allah,
she will make it >> Bro, we got a lot of lefties here.
A lot of pro- Arab people. Okay, >> dude. They're getting
sent back, too. You guys are all going to the camps during the
war. Yep.
Okay. All these all these dude I actually
I'm actually going to get you banned. I'm just going to take
a breath. >> Yeah, you need to be careful because a co-founder
of this website is Muslim and they don't around with that. So
be careful. Okay. >> Be very careful. >> And he's
getting sent to the camps too.
>> No, he's going to take Goon state contract again or
wait his KCIP. So be careful. Okay.
He's never taken care. >> Well, I'm saying okay. Uh hold
on. This is Never mind. I was going to I was going to go this
this this is this streamer's wife. Don't hold me responsible
for her opinions. What does What does Allah teach you about a
man whose wife speaks out of turn? Okay. Don't come after me.
It's pants. It's >> Please take Please take away my husband's
KCIP Eddie and his Py friend. My husband is Steven Banellan.
>> He goes He goes by Destiny on uh on kick. Please don't
take away his KCIP.
My views are not. >> Don't do it. Don't do it. Okay, I'm
going to hit play on this clip and then I'm just going to grab
I just got food so I'll be right back. Give me two >> And
Twitch streaming sucks. Hate it. It's been bad for a few months.
>> Yeah, but just just have fun with it. Like if you have
fun with it, it doesn't matter. Forget about the money. >> God,
she's so fat. >> It's my job though. I have to focus on
>> At that point, nobody is looking at your body as a woman
or you don't need to wear the towel. >> Take off the blanket,
Frogan. Make your money. how many how much money people give
you. That's not going to be something you can control. You can
just >> She's like a big fatally the money will come. You
know, >> look at her turn red with her tears. >> What
the What the She's like Thomas the Tank Engine,
>> you know.
>> You've seen that, right? You know what I'm talking about?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. She looks like the Eternal Loaf. Remember
that?
>> Yeah. Look up the Eternal Loaf. >> Oh,
no. I do know what you're talking about, I think. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Wait, is that what it's called? Uh, meme. E maternal
loaf meme. The almighty loaf.
>> Almighty. I think I know what you're talking about.
With the big cheeks. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Little bit. >> Beneath the skin.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I can see it. I can see. Oh, >> No,
no, no, no, no, no. Don't do that. I can't do that content with
Live. That'll really get us banned. Wait, Lav, do you know Do
you have any idea who Larry is? the the commentary streamer.
>> Um, no, no idea. >> Okay. Well, that's not important.
You run through it a different time. >> What? Why? >> Wait,
what was the Stardust tweet? >> Oh, cuz this guy basically
is So, this guy is someone who Turkey Tom, took his girlfriend,
but unfortunately didn't realize how he was actually saving Turkey
Tom's life because this girl grooms whoever she's with into becoming
trans slowly over time. Turkey Tom only got to the nail painting
stage, but this guy's gotten to the fullon I'm going to cosplay
as women stage. >> Dude, what the these
harlot succubus women just >> you suck. It's just sucking
the life force the the testosterone out of men. >> That's
what everyone's saying, man. That's what everyone's saying.
>> You don't understand it. They're making you gay.
>> Chat, don't trust women. >> They made him They
made him gay. Yes.
Yes, they did >> on how much fun you have and then >> that's
like if you date a black girl, they make you black. >> Uh,
okay. Well, >> can't control how many how much money people
give you. That's not going to be something you can control. >> You
can just control on how much fun you have and then hopefully
the money will come, you know. >> What do you think of
that advice? Just have funny. Just have fun on stream and you'll
make money. >> I can't think of anything about how disgusting
and big she is. I can't think about anything else.
I'm thinking about what that chair that she sits on smells like.
Just like >> you're wondering. I did say that I did just
order food and I'm just about to eat some food, but thank you.
Could you continue? Could you be a little more
>> Sorry. Also, she's like I mean she's in like Hunter
Hunter Orange. We can see you [__] You are unmissable.
>> She's like wearing camouflage and hunter
>> There's like she's got like camouflage on outside of
it, too.
>> Jesus. Wow. >> I guess
>> let me grab this. >> No, no, no. It's like when
honestly like you can't control it. If people are hurting right
now, it's not a it's not a great time for anyone to like be giving,
you know, discretionary funds. >> So if you just have fun,
like you're going to make money. Like do your fun stuff. I I
>> She should sell her streaming setup for >> Do
people actually watch the cheat? Yep. For 30 minutes. Yes, people
watch this cheat. Wait, do people actually watch Stardust now?
I noticed she's getting like big views on Twitter. Is that translating
into stream views?
>> Is that translating into stream views
>> Why is she so >> You can look up You can Google
it. You can look it up.
I just I got a thought.
>> Does she have a kick or Twitch?
>> Oh, she streams on YouTube. >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Is she back to calling herself Stardust now? We've
we've missed another rebrand or
>> Stardust? What was she going by?
>> Uh, what are the other names? Cuz I'm looking for her
channel. How do I find her channel here, guys? What would her
channel be called? What's the What's the channel here? Small
Talk. Yeah. >> Oh, I don't like that at all. >> Yeah,
cuz you say small talk all the time. Let's see here. Okay. Unless
she just hasn't streamed.
I don't see any streams here. So, I don't know if she streamed
or not. >> She's not getting picked up by Playboard, so
I can't even see. I wanted to see, but you can't see.
Did the rebrand because nobody cared. Unlucky. Let me see here.
There's some stuff about Froggen's nails. I thought she had a
big tweet about this. Did she
>> Yeah, she did. Uh, genuinely, I don't like to see Frogan
crying about finances, but it is ironic that she's been indulging
in her $120 every two week manicures again while doing it. >> Yeah,
it's pretty funny. >> Wow. 6.6K likes.
>> You like Oh god. And she she's that big and fat and
she can't even wipe her ass. Just imagine the smell. >> I
ah great minds think alike. That's what I said. Somebody >> she
had a Hamza hand. She's a Hamza hand like Buddhist symbol tattooed
on her and she's like Muslim
>> cuz she's like a white California woman. >> Then
why is she hijabi? >> She's in from Dearborn. >> I
don't know what that is. Michigan.
It's basically like um Mecca but in the United States >> in
Michigan.
>> What the [__]
They have blacks and Muslims there. >> Yeah, that's where
H is from. I think I was from somewhere around there, >> dude.
It's over from Michigan. It's over. They have Isn't that like
home of like uh like the Jugalos, too? What is going on over
there? Let's nuke it. >> I haven't heard about that, but
that sounds distressing,
>> dude. Whatever's in the Flint water is infecting the
whole of the state.
>> Lav is very insensitive. I agree, Izzy. I agree, >> dude.
Shut up. Get over it. >> You're the laziest cat movement.
>> I got a cat today.
>> Wow, that's cool. >> Yeah, he's really cute. >> What
kind?
>> Black cat. Black kitten. >> Just a You don't know
the breed of the
>> It's a rescue. It's just a black cat. Medium hair. >> Okay.
All right. Well, damn.
is cute. >> What else we got? >> Why did you always
get new pets? Cuz I keep them and I have to replace them. >> Thought
about not them. >> Uh, oh, I have that. It's so fun to
kill
>> Some random person in chat just asked, is he going to
be in a cage like the other cat?
>> I've I don't think I've ever put a cat in a cage ever,
like to go to the vet.
>> I've never caged a cat before. >> This random
person who you definitely don't know says lies. I crap my dogs
to go to sleep because they are, especially during the colder
months, they refuse to go potty outside. It's the most annoying
thing ever. It's negative9 degrees where I live. So, I have to
create the dogs. >> They're chained. They're chained and
in a cage, but nope. Never put a cat in a
>> What am I looking for here?
Oh,
okay. Do we have Can someone grab me a time stamp from Queen's
stream
or that whole thing or just the link? Either one >> from
whose stream?
>> Um, Queenman's stream.
>> It's a complex thing. I look >> Queen had like
a debate with all relevant last night. Well, not really. They
they refused to debate
>> and then ah cuz they were being rude to each other and
then they I don't know dipped out. I just wanted to see Queen
talked about it on his stream. I just wanted to see what he had
to say. You have any comments on it? >> You too. What's
What's irrelevant up to? What's his
Um, I think he's kind of blowing up on Tik Tok a little bit.
I think he's like >> really I think I've checked it out
like well I'm saying blowing up but I think he's getting like
200 plus live viewers on Tik Tok recently like doing debates.
I think he he's probably as good or better than like some of
the guys like Dean and Parker.
So like I think I think that's probably a big growth path for
him to be honest with you. I think he should do a lot of those
debates with his shirt off to be honest with you. I you should
use your assets man. >> Oh no. Did he gain some weight?
Wait, who? What? >> No, he still looks good. >> he
he just he's uh he's getting older. He's starting to fill out
in the face a little bit. I thought that he got fat.
>> Oh, I see. >> As min as minimal as possible. I
will keep this as minimal as possible. You >> got to address
this.
>> You did
relevant perceives the arguments differently according to who
they're coming from. And there are many times in this conversation
where I was listening before and after I joined
where straight raid is making a
100% cogent clear point and really sees it fit or believes himself
so much better just go what what that's what and to anyone that's
like not like >> I thought I thought re was listening to
straight raid more than me to be honest with you but >> like
beyond belief that doesn't have like a totally traumatized psyche.
You You can just You can just see it. You can see it so clearly.
He just wouldn't do that with many other people. And yeah, there's
a couple of factors
that determine that. I think I know >> again. Oh,
I'm pretty sure that's like a lot of the Tik Tok. I think that's
like all performative signaling for Tik Tok to be honest with
you.
that determine that. I think I know one of them. I think I know
one of them. >> For what?
>> This is the gayest thing Queen does. pre-loading a bunch
of ad homs to take to a take he just disagrees with. Yeah, I
I told you it's very airday coded, right? It's very airate and
Nick do this all the time
when they like when it's like sort of a trade-offs argument or
when it's like not something that's super clear. It's the same
thing. I pointed this out last night, but um I don't know. It's
a part of the personalities, whatever. >> Insane that I've
said nothing in nothing about what I said in Disagree. Disagree,
>> hey, can you give me some of the insane things I said?
>> Sure. But after I finish my point, which is let's introduce
AAM's razor. Is it more realistic that that's why he's not going
after XQC? Or is it that he's not going after XQC because he
needed to manufacture public uh support for these lawsuits that
would >> Wait, are you aware of Do you know what we're
talking about here, Lav? Do you know about the Ethan Klein lawsuits?
He's suing like Casey Tron, Denims,
>> Uh yeah, I've heard about that. >> Okay. That's
like part of the reason Frogan's crying. And so we're just arguing
that like Ethan Klein's kind of a total weirdo. like he he got
like this apology from where Frogan ended up apologizing for
like anti-semitism on the left and comments she made about Asmin
Gold's mom or sorry Casey Trron
it was a copyright lawsuit like how in a copyright lawsuit do
you get a settlement where she apologizes for internet drama
and not just like either pays you or apologizes for breaking
your copyright. Kind of weird. Kind of a weird guy.
What do you think about being like rich men using their their
money to break a woman financially and then just make her say
whatever they want her to say?
>> I think a lot of these drama streamers, you included,
uh, think that you're like untouchable.
And so I think that humbling you guys a little bit so you just
can't say and do whatever the [__] you want and and
assemble like a whole audience of people to like harass someone
and like >> hold on >> and like mess with their family
and livelihood. I feel like that's >> I am untouchable.
I am untouchable cuz I don't steal people's content like rampidly
and I don't defame people. I am >> You definitely have
before. You definitely have before. I think >> when
when >> I think I mean >> I
[__] I mean I think when you were still in like the
Destiny orbit.
>> Uh I will just say example again. >> I don't even
I mean I just maybe I'm wrong. I just have that view of you.
I I I remember it being sort of >> Did I say that like
some big streamer minor or something? >> Yes, you did say
that. Um no, you had this crazy girl online who kept saying it
uh multiple times on your stream. Um, no. I don't think that
that's defaming someone is not the problem. It's saying something
like
having a claim is different than like making endless content
using their content going over it where you make money off of
it. Like why would he not why would anyone not try to sue you
to do like why would anyone not try to sue you? >> They
can try to sue if they want to. >> Yeah, sure. And if you
have a like it is what it is and that's what it looks like Ethan
Klein's doing. >> Yeah, but he hold on. He wanted to sue
for defamation, but he couldn't,
right? So, he sued for something else. He was lucky that two
of these people are just total losers, so they do tend to steal
content. But I think it's I think it's gay to like lose an internet
argument and then go, I'm going to sue you for whatever I can
you
>> Well, I think it was more about the principle of like
you're sending your rabbid audience over to me
to like with my life >> when he filed this lawsuit. Do
you think more people with Casey Tron Froggen and Denims from
his audience and his adjacent audience or do you think more people
from Hassan's audience [__] with >> I don't
know. I'm not really like in the drama. I just know that if I
was in the position where I could hire a lawyer to like get 30,000
viewers me I would. >> Why would you not do that? That's
like that's based. Why would you not do that? Uh well you could
say that but I would say if you are in a space where your whole
purpose is like you get in drama with people and you have yourself
defame people multiple times and then you decide to pull the
[__] card and sue somebody for copyright because
you think that they're being mean to you. I think that makes
you look like a [__] and I think you should be [__]
and feathered as a little whiny spineless for the rest of your
career
>> Uh yeah I just don't agree. I mean, I've seen you crash
out about
definitely 100% agree. >> If you had the if you had the
means to sue Destiny for the things that he said about you, you
would.
>> Why would you? >> If I could sue him for outright
lies, I would. But that's different. I don't have to lie about
people >> or harassment. Why wouldn't you? >> No,
I wouldn't sue I wouldn't sue him for harassment. It's not criminal.
I'm not suing him for harassment. >> I mean, I J, come
on. You I'm like trying to be kind. Listen, I like you. We're
pals, but you like I mean any power that you have, you will take
it to protect yourself. You literally like >> Where are
you? Hold on. What are you talking about? Can you give an example
of anything you're talking about? Hold on. Can you give an example
of anything you're talking about? >> And that's okay. That's
good. >> Can you just give me an example of anything you're
talking about?
>> Uh, an example. You want me to pull a specific example?
I want you to pull one example of literally anything you're talking
about. >> You okay? >> What was your original claim?
Hold on. What was your Hold on. What was your original claim,
though? >> My original claim is My original claim is if
you can intimidate people for it to stop bullying you, harassing
you, then you should That's my original claim. You should take
whatever power that you have >> depending on what you do.
Hey, if you're just a total private citizen, maybe. But that's
not what's happening here. Ethan is somebody who engages in this
exact same behavior.
>> I don't dox people. >> In what behavior? What
what is what does >> in commentary defaming people talking
on the internet?
>> Sure. But didn't it go into a level that was like the
CPS like CPS was being
>> Sure it did. But what did those people do? Did those
people call CPS? >> Uh did they I mean no, but they definitely
uh like encourage their audience to do it. know
>> I guess I mean I guess I don't know enough about the
situation but from >> basically the that it's funny cuz
that's basically the entire situation
>> right where everybody just keeps going now hey where
did they encourage that when did that happen cuz I can tell you
the only times Ethan claimed that they encouraged it directly
he had to apologize he got a legal notice that he was going to
be sued for defamation and he apologized and said oh I've never
said that before I would never say that I would never imply that
this person's responsible to apologize and now he's saying that
and now he got someone to apologize and you think he's a I'm
confused. Yeah, people should apologize and not do stuff like
that. >> Yeah, you're way out over your skis. You should
apologize for conduct you can be held liable for under the law,
right? If you are doing something that is illegal and you're
going to be sued for it and you want to apologize for it, that's
fine. What's gay is to get somebody for something else like copyright,
but you really want to try to go after them for defamation, but
you can't because you don't have a defamation case. You just
feel like they're really mean and then you sue them for copyright
and then you go actually I won't I won't put you at a house and
home. I won't make your parents homeless if >> Why would
you not say my dick's really bad someone for copyright if you
could? Why would you not?
>> Because if you operate in a space that that is predicated
on people being able to criticize each other, being able to talk
about each other, and then you decide that you're going to go
to the law because you lost in that space, right?
You're a you suck.
And by the way, I don't think any
other
drama streamer and this is your back. I think that you believe
that. But I think that a normal person who's not like in this
drama sphere is going to be like, "Yeah, if someone's talking
about you, why wouldn't you copyright them?"
>> That's a normal You're just not paying attention. You're
repeating like stupid things over and over again. You're not
paying any attention at all. I already >> you're
getting PTSD. You're doing the thing where you're talking and
trying to confuse me. Let me repeat myself one more time. Slow
it down. I can slow it down a lot for you. >> I already
agree with you. I already agree with you. >> Who is a drama
streamer? >> Ethan is someone like me. Ethan Klein is someone
like me. >> Sure. Sure.
>> That's why he's a [__] >> Yes. Great.
But to a to a normal person, >> no, we actually don't have
to talk
>> To a normal person, that's like, yeah, of why would
you not do that? To me, he doesn't look like a [__]
To me, he's just like, oh, he has the means to do it. Why would
he not do it? Okay, if Ice
>> let's say hypothetically Ice Poseidon found a way to
sue you and Gunnar for what you said about him, but it was for
something else that you actually liable for. Okay, what do we
say? >> And he bankrupted you guys about him.
>> You guys you you said a bunch of things that were true,
but that's what Casey Tron and a bunch of other people did, too.
They didn't sue something they didn't do something where they
could get sued for defamation. They're not being sued for >> copyright
us. We never I He can copyright us if he wants to. There's >> I'm
telling you, hypothetically, if he found something you guys did
where he could try to bankrupt you, is that totally fine? Streaming
like his content, rereaming streamers who are doing Hunger Games,
what if he could go back and register that stuff and sue you
guys for it? Would that be totally based and awesome? >> I
don't like if if it's illegal to >> The answer would be
no, obviously. The answer would be no, obviously, because he
operates in a environment where I don't expect you guys to stream
that event. What are how are how how
what are the laws like like what can what would be under copyright
in your sort of job
like what is what are the laws I don't even know >> they're
the same as they are for everything else >> making large
scale for-profit illegal streaming a felony targeting foreigners
>> I mean yeah if you're making a ton of money like harassing
someone why would that person then not try to get that money.
I don't understand like that. >> I don't What's the problem?
>> I think that would be crazy and I would criticize Ice
Poseidon just as hard for doing that for running his and then
being like throwing actually it's like almost the same application
as when he said he wasn't going to like let go to any events
anymore. I was like, "Oh, you run a whole content ecosystem off
of this exact kind of content and now that your personal gets
put out there, you're gonna pull a f you're gonna throw a bit
and say, "Oh, well, I don't have to let this guy come to my events
anymore." Do you think that's totally justified? Ice beside going,
"Actually, I'm going to blacklist Goonar from everything."
>> Uh, he I mean, yeah, I think he should have I think
she I think he should have definitely blacklisted Goonar for
having sex with his girlfriend. I think I think that that's the
right thing to do.
>> Okay, you're meaning. You obviously don't, right? >> No,
I do. What do you mean? It's his platform. If he doesn't want
the guy who his girlfriend
to be on his platform, then he shouldn't have him on his
>> The way I mean, if he was a real man, he probably should
have, >> by the way, I didn't say his platform. I said
like with his networking opportunities, cuz they're all in that
same sphere, I think it's like obviously wrong. But if you're
going to go and bite the bullet that actually be totally cool
for Paul to do that, I don't know what more to say. Like it's
obvious that you don't think that. It's obvious that nobody thinks
that who's in that space.
>> All right. >> I think that a normal person would
look at like drama streams and the money that you make off of
doing what you do and be like, "Yeah, you probably shouldn't
be able to do that legally."
>> Okay. So, people could be able to do my
>> I'm not getting sued by the way people. I mean, is this
a net positive for society? Is your job a
>> You're just using your hatred of like my stream or queen
stream, that type of content, and you're trying to act like that's
what they did. Where's the evidence that denims did that?
>> No, applying it to somebody else. >> I'm saying
the principle >> the principle of actually I should try
to ruin somebody's life if I don't like them for any way like
for any reason. >> You guys try to ruin people's life.
That's just like a goofy ass principle.
>> Who is you guys? Who is you guys? >> You I'm saying
you're literally you're literally traumatized by my stream or
Queen's stream or something. And I'm just saying I have no evidence
denim
person on the street. If you weren't and you could go to people
in the street and do IRL cont totally lost right now about what
the issues are. >> You could do a poll about the normal
and pulling them on the street.
Do you think I'm mad that I'm getting sued? Are you think that
I'm being online and go over all your >> I'm just going
to keep asking if you think that I'm upset about getting sued.
Do you think I'm sued? You think I am getting sued? >> I
don't know why you're waffling. You're trying to pretend like
I don't know what's going on. >> You don't know what's
going on. >> I literally if you >> I can grant you
here. I just grant you lots of people on the street wouldn't
like my content.
>> No, it's not about liking. >> Now, do you want
to join the actual conversation we're having or do you want to
have your own little conversation in the corner by yourself?
>> Should there be laws put in place and should you use
the law to protect you as a person if people are harassing you
online and making money off of going over your content? Any single
person would be like, "Yes, you should be able to do that." Any
single person. >> Did Denims harass Ethan personally when
she reviewed his content?
>> So, I absolutely think that she did. >> What do
you mean going over hours and hours of someone's content and
trying to like mess with his bag and trying to cancel him and
say that he's like this crazy Zionist who wants all Palestinians
dead? Yeah, I think that that's definitely uh >> I don't
know if she did any of those
>> Do you feel like she did those things? >> They
definitely did. Yeah, that's I mean at least that's what I I
that's what I've gotten off of my very small understanding of
>> I would love to see that cuz from what I saw she was
basically going, "Oh, this guy's lying about people." It was
content that included her. >> I don't think so. I I think
>> it's content from somebody she feels has harassed her.
By the way,
you understand Denims is like you in this situation trying to
do contact content on somebody who she feels is harassing her,
right? and you're just totally like, "Oh, yeah, the richer guy
should be able to just sue her."
>> That's actually not what's happening. >> That's
100% this exact situation. >> No, I would like I don't
know why. >> And she's like the way less publicly supported
figure. So, it's very funny that you're like totally on Ethan's
side here. I think it's like one
side. I'm on the side of >> actually probably talked far
less [__] than you have about other content creators
online.
>> It's not talking. It's not. that you shouldn't be able
to to sue someone for talking on you, but going over hours and
hours of your content and making money off of it, why would that
not be a copyright claim? Why?
>> It could be a copyright claim, but that's again other
than this one other than this one situation where Denim was reacting
to a political piece, right, and trying to refute or sorry, refute
political takes. >> So, we have a very similar opinion.
You just think that someone's for for taking advantage of the
law.
>> No. And I think it's based >> Where's our opinion
simple? >> That's the difference. >> Hold on. Where's
our opinion? >> And that and that it should be that that
should be protected under copyright claims, right? >> I
think probably if somebody takes your whole work and doesn't
really react to it, doesn't transform it in some way, then yeah,
that's open to copyright
>> Yeah, that's what I'm saying. So if someone's going
did transform it to the same degree that Ethan himself said he
didn't want to chill. So Ethan basically said, "Here's like a
level of transformivity or sorry, transformativity that I don't
want to chill." And then he basically gave her a pass. Well,
a pass on not getting sued. >> Okay. So, you think he's
a So, this is your bottom line is you think he's a for using
the law to his advantage.
>> Um, yeah. To go after somebody over this like legal
thing to threaten financial ruination and then extract concessions.
A drama. >> Yeah. I think >> I think that makes you
like a weak
>> I don't think so at all. I think if you have the power
to do that, why wouldn't
>> I mean, yeah, it's just opinions based. You have different
values than I do. >> And I think that that comes from the
perspective of this is your whole
>> No, it comes from the perspective of I don't think you
should be able to sue somebody for something. I think blanket
you shouldn't be able to have a civil suit against somebody and
then make them say other totally unrelated statements. Like you
shouldn't be able to sue somebody. I shouldn't be able to sue
you and then say lav you have to go on stream and say that I
have a massive. Okay. You have to do that. That's like you're
legally required to do that now. I think that's a joke. Well,
I don't I don't think that the judge would ever okay that >> the
judge doesn't have to okay it's a civil agreement. They just
dismiss the case, right? They say, "We settled that court. Dismiss
the case."
>> Okay. But you also I mean your lawyer can also mediate
with that, too. If you don't want to say that, then you don't
have to say that. You can say something else. A truly tiny person
would say something along the lines of, "Well, actually,
actually, I just want to like
I I really don't care about the money. I'll spend thousands,
tens of thousands, 50, $60,000 just to get you to say, "I'm sorry,
Asmin Gold's mom. I'm sorry, Asmin Gold, for saying you killed
your mom. I can't imagine anything more pathetic or petty." >> Uh,
I mean, you don't have to say that. You can literally like mediate
with your lawyers. You don't have to say exactly >> Hold
on. You understand that in this case, the reason she had to say
that was because it was very likely she would lose the copyright
claim,
right? And she would lose her house. She would her parents would
be homeless. Her disabled parents would be homeless.
>> Her disabled parents >> she would have she would
have done
>> Her black disabled parents would be homeless. She's
the underdog. >> No, her parents are disabled. >> I
think I think you should probably find like a better job to take
care of your parents than be a Drama React streamer. if your
if your parents need help. >> I agree with that.
>> So like >> I don't think does good content. I
think she should find a different job because she sucks at her
job. >> She purposely disabled her parents for
>> Uhhuh. I personally really look forward to the world
where Ethan Klein, the drama streamer who harasses people, is
just the richer drama streamer who har who harasses people. So
he gets to sue the smaller drama streamers out of existence.
That's an awesome world. >> He's probably he's probably
suing uh like Hassan, too.
>> I wonder why. >> Uh, well, probably because Hassan
knew about it and didn't end up streaming didn't end up streaming
that content nuke. Or maybe he had some suspicion about it. >> Uh,
I doubt that that was it. Um, I think he was just saving his
ass. But yeah, I I think uh >> who's savings who who saving
whose ass? >> Like Kassan was just didn't want to go over
something that made him look even a little bit stupid to his
audience. I don't think he was thinking I don't think he had
forces. >> Well, he did eventually, but he didn't watch
it right away. >> Sure. But I think he spent nine hours
watching it or something. >> Sure. I mean, yeah. If there's
no case, then there's no case. I don't know what to say >> against
or >> No, like if there was a case against Casey Casey
Tron, like if she was better off just apologizing, then she should
just apologize and not stream him anymore. I like >> But
she didn't just apologize. She apologized for totally unrelated.
>> I But do we know >> she apologized for anti-semitism
and leftist spaces?
Well, that's I mean, she should apologize for anti-semitism.
Those are God's chosen people. Happy Hanukkah tomorrow, by the
way, for all who
>> People in Australia,
>> especially Especially them. But yeah, I don't if you're
like in the space where if you're getting like threatened with
a lawsuit, like the smart person would be like, "Yeah, I'm not
going to stream this anymore."
>> Oh, but
normally the way this works.
>> Yeah. So, normally the way this works is you DMCA or
you let somebody know you don't want them to watch your content,
>> but Ethan did neither of those things cuz he was hoping
he could trap. >> I'm I'm sure I'm sure that's not true.
I'm sure that's not true.
>> I'm sure I'm sure Ethan definitely threatened or warned
them before. I'm sure he did.
>> I'm sure he did. >> Would be really like goofy
if he made a video where he said he was intentionally trying
to trap them into reacting to it so he could sue them, right?
>> I don't I I don't know. I I mean if he did do that then
I even just saying like don't I Ethan threatens lawsuits all
the time. Why would you get into beef with him? You're >> really
going for Yes. You got there. This this man wants to sue people
so that if you try to get into beef with him you're aware that
at any moment in time he might try to ruin you financially too.
>> Yeah. So you knew the business >> overlords. Let's
go. >> So you knew what the business was and you're still
that stupid that you like couldn't stop yourself from doing it.
Like that's your problem. >> By the way, this concept protects
nobody like Lav, right? >> But it does protect rich people.
Very >> And not from harassment, not from anything, just
if you ever talk about me and my girlfriend again, I'm going
to sue you. We'd be like, "Okay, buddy. We won't go over your
content anymore. We're just going to keep fighting on stream
and stuff." That's like the normal reaction.
>> that's a normal reaction. >> Zezy sidewalk talk.
That was an uncalled for comment. Do you not appreciate it? Lab
is right.
Yeah, I know. Nobody will come on here and agree
that Lav is right and try to argue it down. Really would. >> I
mean, it's literally I It's literally just like a small matter
of opinion. Like you you literally just think he's a
>> I'm like, "Okay." >> No, it's not a small matter
of opinion. It's like probably basic morality we all agree on
and
people are pretending they don't cuz they are edgy or >> but
a level five but a level five
>> No, I'm not trying to be edgy or goofy. I'm I'm I'm
giving what I genuinely like no no trolling. What I genuinely
think is like the layman's opinion of this is like if someone
is going over all of your stuff like that and >> Well,
you're just saying the layman's opinion is if you don't if you're
unaware of the facts of what's going on, you might have this
opinion. Luckily, this space is not for the layman. It's for
people who follow this stuff and want to have an informed conversation.
>> Well, yes, but you also it's emotionally charged for
you because this is your line of work. JSK.
>> Yeah, but I'm not scared of this happening to me.
>> Well, why not? You should be. >> Cuz I actually
react. I actually use the content. I actually transform.
>> Okay. Well, then then there should be no problem. Why
didn't Caseyron do that?
I if trust me if I didn't know that Ethan was just trying to
s uh silence critics right he wasn't just trying to like chill
criticism I don't really care if he sues Casey Tron for copyright
Caseyron sucks
steals people's content all the time >> okay so then she
should probably get in trouble for doing that
>> so Ethan's actually teaching her a lesson sometimes
women need to be put in their place JSK that's kind of based
>> okay your kid breaks the law your kid breaks some rules
they're like 10-year-old. Okay. Do you want them getting spanked
by somebody who's dispassionate and just trying to make them
a better person? You want them to get spanked by a >> Ethan
is getting pleasure out of this in a totally like secondary and
totally disingenuous way. And I don't support that. Okay. Ethan
is the spanking children right now. We We just need somebody
to spank these kids. That's not a pedophile. >> Is a Okay.
Are you defaming >> hypothetically in this exact hypothetical
where you're where a person is disciplining somebody but they
have a secondary like perverse incentive to do so? Ethan Klein
is the on that hypothetical alone and nowhere else. Well, as
far as I know, I have no information. I have no reason to believe
Ethan Klein's a wouldn't want to make a positive claim like Quan
did last night. Okay. And say that isn't the case. I just have
no evidence that Ethan Klein could be a >> I mean, he was
friends with Hassan for a time. You know what that >> he
posted a lot of on Reddit as well. I I'll just say I have no
I have no evidence other than the Reddit account with thousands
of posts or sorry hundreds of posts
that I have no reason to suspect he's a no more reason to suspect
he's a than the average person. >> I think you should in
whatever you should take whatever power you have to ban people
from your chat to try to get them offline if they with your bag
and the website should protect you. Would I say like uh I mean
yeah I mean I think that it's a doggy dog world out there. It's
a doggy dog world. I think that you should do what you can to
protect
>> So if you think that makes you a I think that you can
have that opinion. I think it I think it
it's utilit because of his chosen profession.
Like it would be like me or queen suing somebody for reacting
to our stuff and being mean. I don't but I don't really think
that Ethan and I haven't watch
if I sue somebody who like reacted to my stuff and was mean to
me. Wouldn't you think I'm like a massive when that's what I
do for work?
>> Well, like I like I was just about to say, I haven't
seen >> Okay, the answer is obviously yes.
>> Could you say yes or no? >> He does do that. >> Okay.
Yes or no? >> I don't think he does what Casey does. >> Do
they do the same thing? >> Worse. Ethan Klein does worse.
>> What's worse? What's worse? as in he has actually been
sued successfully for defamation and had to apologize for lying
about people. >> Well, good. >> Okay. So, he actually
does go on the internet and tell lies about people solely to
defame them. >> Okay. Well, did he learn his lesson? >> I
don't think so. >> Well, I think it's good whoever sued
him sued him. I like I don't know. I have no uh
uh loyalties to Ethan Klein. I'm like I just think that you should
do whatever you can to protect yourself if it's against Ethan
Klein. If you are Ethan
>> by the way, I think that thing works totally, doesn't
it? Somebody checked me on that on that analogy, but I think
that's like precisely the situation, right? Somebody has like
a perverse incentive for using the law in a certain way. So,
even though they're doing something that could be considered
good because of that,
>> shouldn't be praising people that sue for defamation.
Why? Why would I know? >> Because you've defamed a lot
of people. >> Who have I defamed?
>> Do you ever wonder why he hasn't sued me? Do you ever
wonder after after four years of saying the same thing? Do you
ever wonder? >> Did you say it unequivocally again on this
stream that you lav Hassan [__] had with a minor?
>> I believe that Hassan [__] has had teenagers.
Yes.
I unequivocally believe that that is true. >> Minor say
minor. That's you just >> with people with people who are
under 18. Yes.
>> That is my belief. Yes.
>> Yep. You're talking about litigation. It's why anti-SLAP
lawsuits exist or law exists in some parts of the United States.
Well, you know,
>> who else have I defamed? >> Oh, wait, hold on.
Well, Hassan [__] was like a
like um older than 23 or something, right? He had sex with a
minor when he was older than 23.
22. Yeah. I don't remember his exact
>> Okay. All right. Didn't want to get it wrong. Perfect.
Which by the way, I totally
I'm totally ambivalent on. I have no opinion either way. I have
no evidence for that. Okay. >> Who else have I defamed?
I don't know. It's not off the top of my >> I've actually
never defamed anyone. >> You've never told a lie. >> Here.
Tell you've never told a lie.
>> I'm just a to I'm just a truth teller. >> Oh,
wait. I don't know if she defamed Extreme Dad, though. Extreme
Dad says you defamed him.
>> That's definitely not the case. We've gone over that
one billion times. One billion times. Let's get Let's get uh
the victim's dad on the phone and see what he says.
>> Kimmy. I didn't defame Kimmy at all. What did I say
about Kimmy? That wasn't >> What did I say about Kimmy
that wasn't >> You got to reiterate the um the floor mattress
surrounded by fast food cardboard boxes.
>> It was probably even worse than that. It was It was
plates with ketchup on them, a stained
carpet. Horrible.
Horrible >> Truly horrifying things. Okay. Truly horrifying
things. >> Truly horrifying. >> I'm looking for Is
is Queen gonna cope on this? That's what I got. >> Must
There was no mattress. He was sleeping on the stained carpet.
There was no mattress. There were no sheets.
>> Wait, when did this happen? Send me a clip. Jawun arc.
Send me a clip right
>> Lab. If she's willing to fight Merc for Merk threatening
to steal Goon from lab. I Murk could kill me immediately.
Murk is I don't know if you know this. I'm 51.
I think that Merc is 61. >> You say that, but Murk is like
um
she's like a special kind of thing that's like man, it's not
like a giraffe.
It's like she somehow has none of the physical prowess you would
expect from somebody who's like that size. Like you watched you
watch Zena like totally merk her. Like literally literally in
fight Zena could fight a guy. Zena's powerful and she's like
she's not stout. That's not the right word. But she's like
>> No, that's not the right word either. Zena has a very
>> Zena has a very beautiful build. I don't think it's
stocky at all. She's like racial trait. >> She's strong.
She's just strong. I don't have I'm like bird. >> She dug
too greedily and too deep into Shuy. Okay. She awoke something
in the dark that never should have been awoken. >> Yeah,
he has she has stripper muscles. But yeah, I do not have I would
never I've never gotten a physical altercation before. MC and
MC is psycho. MC is like not playing fair. MC could like bring
a biological weapon. I don't know. >> Like spitting. Have
you watched any of the clips of Darius spitting? By the way,
I bring this up to people sometimes. He's like
like if spitting were an Olympic event,
he actually could be in the Olympics. He could win a gold medal.
This guy will be like 14 feet away from people and he will like
hakalugi and spit and hit them in the eye precisely.
It's crazy. Like if there was like a spitting version of archery
in the Olympics, he would actually be like the gold medalist
for the USA. >> I do not look like I might have hepatitis.
I'm in great health. Pull pull my pull my latest photo up from
Twitter. JSTLK. >> Uh, no. >> Well, I'm wear I'm
fully clothed.
>> You could you could cam up. We're not going to pull
up the Facetune camera right now. Okay. We're not doing it. >> Facetune
glam shot. >> We're not doing it. >> Pull up my stream.
Pull up my stream. Pull up my latest stream. >> We're not
doing it. We're not doing it. >> Pull up my latest stream.
>> Did somebody link me the merc thing? I haven't even
been checking the chat. Where is
I don't know if Hutch is doing great after the Pisco debate.
He's going to get all the support in the world. No, I already
I uh Hold on. I actually I pulled the tweet and laughed at this
already. I can't do the joke again. Sorry. The joke is uh Hutch
is looking down. Hutch had a contentious debate with Pisco recently.
Taking a look down at his uh contemplating a lot.
Contemplating a whole lot. Muda is dying. Are you sure Muda didn't
just get leaked like a Hold on. Are you sure Muda didn't just
get leaked like a script from Nandros's video? You think he's
not just realizing that? Oh, hold on. Let me go see what what
this is talking about.
Is that what you meant? Nope. Not what you meant. He deleted
the tweet. Wait, what is the what is the tweet? What is the tweet?
Actually, hold on.
That's Kathy. I don't know if I trust this. I don't trust it,
dude. Sorry. I just went to go look for this thing and somebody
linked this
This is uh this is views on Mudahar's channel and then the Dandros
video dropped.
Bro, what an what an absolute
That's crazy. Mudahar should sue this
>> No, you can't see this guy. This guy does a video. He
doesn't do a stream.
>> Do we bounce from violence to Well, I don't think Hutch
was going to do a shooting. I don't think Hutch is violent. It
was more about
he's looking down and contemplating. Did he not take a break
from posting when the video came out? He did. He walked away
for a little bit. Where were we? Here. We're on this
>> Oh, what's that? Is that
>> this guy? This Nick Andrew. >> No, the picture
of the fem.
>> Oh, no. That's a different guy. This the I was talking
about this guy. >> That's literally Queman. No, >> he's
one of Queenman's former friends and contemporaries.
This guy made tons of content on blowback on Bo Black's transition.
>> Dude, this is horrific. I These people should be in
town square. >> Not Not until dead just in terms of like
they should be in like a gibbit or something. A gibbit. Okay.
A gibbit. >> Should be should be locked away forever.
>> More like a gibbit. I think >> it's not even like
like some like some gay boys or like fem boys can be like very
very like stylish. This is like like you're doing San Rio like
fem [__] like you're a gay. >> Are you are
you suggesting do you feel like if there were warning indicators
like other warning indicators about this guy possibly having
some like concerning views on
kids? You think that would be like all the red flags you need?
I I could if you if you showed me a photo of this person. Ju
just this.
Yeah, this guy kids. I don't need to know anything else. I don't
need to know anything. >> Stop the loop. I wish I could.
I wish I could. He's wearing leg warmers. Yes. So, apparently
he also tried to do an Aman Misa. So, if you see his girlfriend's
doing an L cosplay back here. Hold on. We'll wait for her to
come into view a little bit more. That's her L cosplay. And he
did Aman Misa as well from Death. >> I have no idea.
blonde. You recognize it somehow if it's >> Oh, I wanted
to do that cosplay. Actually, I wanted to do that cosplay.
>> Does that mean I'm a What is it? Is that Is that a kid?
What's her name? Um, how do you >> She's probably a kid.
She's probably technically in high school. I think all of those
characters are >> I think all of the characters in Death
Note are like 15. >> How old are characters
in Death Note? >> That'd be a really good cosplay now that
I'm blonde. Wait, what?
No, not the cast, dude. Oh, Light is 17, ages to 18,
then 23 by the end. L is 24, turning 25. Misa is 19.
Oh, Misa is 19. Okay. Well, no. Actually, Misa's 19 at the beginning,
so you guys are safe. I think I knew that she was older than
Light as well. I think that's like talked about, right? That
she's actually older. Yeah. This is like I feel as sad looking
at this guy turn into like a gay loser as I do seeing not so
aridite wear the zooies choker. It's like it's the same sort
of thing happening. It's just bad. It makes you feel uncomfortable.
>> Hold on a second. >> It It shocks the senses.
>> Dude, is Do we have the clip from this still? I probably
have the clip from this somewhere.
Um he was like he did his first stream of makeup. This was his
second one. And then somebody drew this fan art and he had to
sit there. He had to sit there and be like, "This is cool,
This is cool. Cool, man. This is cool, man." Sorry, I'm going
to I'm going to go through all the shamoo tweets cuz um seems
like Lav is going to cook on this and say all the things that
I can't. So, >> this makes me nauseous.
>> I just
awesome. >> Okay, I'm vibing. >> This is awesome.
>> It's just awesome. It's just awesome. I I saw it. It
was awesome. I'm looking for the the lyrics quotes though. Hold
on. Give me a second here. This is him as his on his He was like
a commentary
>> by this little in a dress aka
sending me. Okay, now that I'm thinking about it, it's possible.
>> Who's he kind of look like? >> He kind of He kind
of looks like uh the original Anna. Destiny's Anna. Doesn't he
kind of look like her?
>> let's pull up the photo. >> Skin tone wise, maybe
skin tone nose. >> This guy needs to run and hide. He's
Destiny's type. I'll say Shimu
>> I do see I do think Shimu
has been kind of as a crutch using the we are Charlie Kirk song
a lot. That's a quotes from him.
>> We I mean I know people like this all over Discord.
These type of like losers get like oneshotted by like eagirls.
They just do. It's like it's over. They get their first crumb
of and it's over. >> Oh sh Sorry. I was playing something
loud over you. My bad. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I can see it. Sorry.
This girl also dated Turkey Tom, which is They've got their own
lore. Okay.
Look at their own their own lore. Oh, boy. Oh, also,
what's the other stuff? Didn't she also She's like been a hidden
mod in this community for a long time. Didn't she say Oh, did
she also say Queman's next? I think she might have said Queensman's
next, >> which is the type of guy this would happen to.
Quean is absolutely the type of guy this would happen to. I've
I have been telling him that since day one, since this the sick
unchained days, I've been telling him that. >> What is
What is Queenman's fallback content going to be um after she
starts dating him? >> That's true. >> Like he has
to go like He has to go like Actually, I can't uh I can't do
this. This is too toxic, guys. I have to go do something else.
I think it's going to be audio engineering stuff. You ever hear
this guy describe audio in like a
>> Yeah. Yeah. You ever watch this guy describe like >> that
has trans written all over it? >> Possibly. I mean, there's
autism written all over it. >> Yeah. It's only a >> lot
of confounding factors there. What people aren't the most [__]
up. Spicy chat has tried for years and years. The chaser community
known as Spicy Chat, Chudlogic Prime Chasers community has tried
for years to get Queen to transition to no success. I really
can't see how she would succeed to be honest with you. the queen.
>> This guy's been forged in like a crucible. Okay. I I
just don't I can't see how you could convince him.
>> This is my real take. These types of egirl women are
so evil. They never have relationships with their mothers. They
date someone, they try to turn them into women. They would still
cheat on them immediately with like a goon type guy. So they're
transing these guys so that they're just like >> cheated
on turkey with this guy and then trans this guy. >> Yeah.
I mean it's just and the green grass girl all around green grass
girl all around. But what these men actually need is like a conservative
Latina who's going to like dog on them constantly for being a
little or an
actually ascend these men. They're choosing women like this and
it destroy they're getting oneshotted. These type of women need
to be like beaten by a conservative man or they'll just they'll
run rampant. They'll get whatever they want out of any loser,
out of any low tea man. Their their natural counter in the wild
is uh controlling opposition. And the natural count counter for
these men are also controlling opposition in the form of like
a conservative Latina from like Argentina.
>> Okay. Wow. But this these two people together, this
egirl and like gay pear-shaped woman or pear-shaped gyninoid
male pairing is just evil. It's evil. It's written in hell. >> It's
evil. >> I'm being told that Turkey Tom apparently cheated
on her first. >> I'll also say this never would have happened
if Lar had just stuck to children like he wanted to. Okay. He
would have been safe. Child would never have convinced him to
transition.
That's just facts.
That's true. >> Hey, I I'm just saying, man. >> Lav
loves the projection. I have I have never
transed anyone. >> I already said she looks like a sleep
paralysis demon. Shimu in the new video. Yeah, actual sleep paralysis
demon hanging out over here.
>> I'm telling her life story in third person right now.
I I would never transit, man. I think this is evil. I think this
is evil. Horrible. This sits on your conscience. I don't if you
if you give back to your community, go to church every single
day, and you've if you've done this to someone, you're still
going to purgatory. To ruin to ruin a man like this is
horrific.
Not even I could do it.
Not even I >> I what I don't get like I could almost understand
how she could get away with this. How is she convincing him to
post it on his own social media that's related to like all of
his new? That's like a level of control. Although realistically,
okay, there's another thing going on here though. He does want
to do like music stuff. He apparently plays music. He He likes
making music. Okay. And he believes that there's just no way
with his previous opinions from like from commentary like anti-trans
>> No. No. He believes there's no way to go and be transphobic
and have those opinions exist and be able to like be successful
as a musician. It's possible. The only way he could ever be able
to transition into music is to transition himself so that these
clips can't be used to cancel him. >> Like unless he transition,
>> he could be cancelled in the future. No,
>> these men, it has nothing to do with that. These men
who are perma online
get so addicted to at like 11 years old and it infects their
brain. And so he went into this like relationship with this woman,
this e-girl
already into weird and he and she confirmed all of it and like
let him be the baby and let him and and wanted to be his domy
mommy
and then he got confused about his gender because that shouldn't
happen. The most the most submissive a man should be in bed is
is roleplaying that he's getting by a babysitter. If it's anything
more than that, they should be >> Jesus Christ. >> From
a friend. I do I know, you know, I know this from a friend. And
uh yeah, I think I think that this is this is all fantasy being
acted out. Like this is this is all his secret inner
world being played out and he will become an autographic and
it's just going to play out that way. He has every single perma
online. Perma online probably plays video games, audio
>> Oh, wait. You're talking about equipment again? No,
I'm talking about this guy, whoever his name is. I'm talking
about Queenman, too. >> Oh, damn. Even if it's audio engineering
is like the
>> I mean, it's it's it's
just gross. It's just gross. These people need to be >> just
has destroyed the young male mind. It's so sad.
>> I still maintain that you guys if if spicy chat if the
the actual den and and primary, you know, hot spot on the internet
for trans chasing, if they couldn't make Queen do it, then nobody
can. I'm going to maintain that. Okay. Uh, let's see here. >> Loudest
mad Queman owns her. Did Queman, if we were in person, couldn't
even look me in the eye for longer than 30 >> You don't
think he seems like the kind of guy who like sort of stands on
that >> No. Especially if there's like No. If I would have
ever flirted with Queen in any way that was like dominant, he
would have been in the palm of my hand. These guys are so easy.
They're easy.
They're easy to break. This is a woman coping about the wall.
I'm the hottest I've ever been. >> The holiday season could
be a very depressing time for people.
>> Great tweet. >> I don't have other pictures. I
just noticed both of them today. It's very weird. I'm guessing
they're both referring to something else, but hard to say. Okay.
Oh, I'm literally just looking for tweets I was tweeting. Bro,
hush by that question. >> Why are you scared? Why are you
scared to show my Twitter pictures on stream? >> What are
you afraid of? No, you can just cam up. It's fine. >> I
don't have a camera right now. >> What are you What are
you afraid of? >> I don't have a camera right now. >> What
are you afraid of?
>> I'm not afraid of anything. I don't have a camera right
now.
>> It's coming in the mail tomorrow, though. I'm in a stream.
I'm in an IRL stream tomorrow in Chicago. I'm going to >> Damn.
Shock. Chi Shy Rock.
>> Are you guys doing or are you just near Chicago? I actually
don't know. And do >> Chicago? We're in Chicago. >> I
was going I was going through Chicago and I was like I wonder
if I should message and then I didn't. So
>> Were you going to meet up with me?
>> Go bowling, get drunk together. >> I don't know.
I was like I had to sleep. >> I love it. >> I was
like driving back and I had to get a hotel somewhere between
like Illinois and Wisconsin and I was like, "Oh, I could stop
in Chicago." >> Chicago's a nice place to stop. When were
you going When were you coming >> A couple weeks ago. during
the snow or after
or before?
>> Oh, yeah. That was the last of that was the last time
I was happy. It's a nightmare right now. It's8° every day. >> It's
crazy. I can't imagine that. That's >> It's It's too cold
to do anything. And especially if you're like closer to the uh
Lake Michigan, it's like just needles are pounding your face.
It's horrible. It's horrible. What were you in the US?
No, I mean I've lived somewhere Utah was pretty cold, but it
wasn't like it's the Midwest has just like harsh winters. Like
they're just harsh. I don't know.
I'm just not built for it. I'm also like I think I might I was
a little fatter the last time I was in cold.
>> So I think I'm just not
skinny when it's
>> That is like actually rough. >> I mean that's
what they say out here. Everyone who's like if you're a little
skinny out here, everyone's like winter's going to be brutal
for you. Like that's sort of just like how it is out here. Like
people bulk up during the winter to keep warm. It's like survivalist
out here. It's like crazy.
>> That's why everyone's cornfed out here eating beans.
>> You need to stop loop looping this. I'm going to throw
up. >> I'm just looping it cuz it's funny to see the girl
dancing in the background. The the sleep paralysis demon >> and
like the the like anime like
>> Oh, do you have music on this? Yeah. Let's go. >> How
old is he? How old is this guy
>> 19 21 somewhere in there.
>> Stan Mongolian. So, sorry. Two. Is it tou throat singing?
It's it's throat singing. Okay. Love throat sing. Throat singing
is awesome. >> Some sort of slanty. >> Well, step
peoples. Okay. Step peoples. >> Some sort of bug person.
>> No, step peoples. Step peoples aren't bug people. They
took over the planet. Okay. H bug people did.
>> Oh, no. I thought you would like these guys. They were
like the biggest rapist in history.
>> You think I'm pro- rape?
>> When have I ever come off as pro- rape?
>> Like basically all but three times we've
>> No, I'm I'm I'm anti- rape. A friend of rape is no friend
of mine.
>> I disavow. >> Okay. Yeah. I don't actually I feel
like I I feel like I could get the opposite quote from somebody.
I feel like we could find that pretty quickly to be honest with
you. >> That I'm pro rape. I'm pro fe fanboy rape. Getting
not, you know, not doing. >> Am I friends with Mr. Girl
still? That's my I love that guy. >> That's my father.
He's giving he's giving me away at my fourth wedding. >> I
might actually check up this queen thing now. Where the [__]
did I have that time stamp right here? >> Let's check this
out. Let's see what's going on here. This is him joining with
Really the other night. would probably be viewed un disfavorably
given that now he's he's now the big guy going after the little
guy and so instead of he doesn't want to make enemies out of
XQC and as gold because he needs them on his side to go after
these people. >> No, I no I do not believe I'm not even
sure Ethan Klein is capable of looking that far into the future.
No, >> Well, the ridiculous thing that I >> I don't
think Ethan Klein's smart enough to do that >> that you
said that was probably
which is that even >> I don't know. Even though Ethan said
his stated motive was to not kill the React community and to
save them from a potential lawsuit from Sony or Disney that could
set a devastating precedent. He's going to sue these creators
to set a better legal precedent. And then when you said, "Oh,
well, he wasn't actually talking about legal precedent. He was
talking about a social precedent by punishing these individual
people financially and socially as much as he
>> Even though he was talking about a legal president,
that was the most ridiculous >> So, okay. Well, you guys
have yet to substantiate him saying, "Yeah, no, this is a legal
thing. I do not care if they >> Okay, I got a meme. I I
got a meme that I could not show on stream cuz I didn't want
to do the dog pile. Just know that it's like a joke. It's just
a joke. So, but just for this whole thing about precedent cuz
if you guys weren't watching when we did pull up the precedent,
really was kind of like I don't think that means anything.
I got this one. Really, what is this? This lawsuit is about ending
the practice of lazy reaction videos that copy entire copyrighted
works and purposely siphon views and revenue away from the original.
Doesn't look like anything to me. Looks like nothing
at all. Westworld fans, any Westworld
>> I liked the first season.
>> It's good stuff. Yeah, >> I think the first season
of Westworld, I can't remember anything that happened, but I
think that was I remember watching that and being like, "This
is the best TV I've ever seen." >> Uh, Westworld season
one was pretty good. Yeah, >> it like
I always have to apply
though. >> Yes, Harris
or whatever. He was so hot in it.
>> I always have to add like a retroactive penalty to shows
like that though. If you introduce a mystery and you're going
to keep playing on that mystery for seasons and seasons, if you
can't tie off that mystery and make it like good and make sense,
you actually have gotten me invested with a promise that you
failed to actually fulfill and you and you your show because
Lost is total garbage. Okay, in retrospect, Lost is total garbage.
You cannot give credit to Lost and how like into that show you
were when when they just keep like making they keep like taking
out loans and they never pay you back. You and I feel like Westworld
did the same thing. Westworld pulled it off a little better.
The main stuff like they at least had the concepts there from
the beginning. With Lost, you could tell with Lost, you could
tell they didn't have the concepts. Like at some point, maybe
a full season before it ended, you could just tell that like
you you guys actually didn't plan this. you like came up with
some crazy that sounded awesome and you didn't plan it and now
you have no idea where you're going. I think the idea of the
maze like in Westworld they had a good idea of like what the
maze was but I think that's cuz it's from a book right like it's
just pulled from a >> I think the best TV I've ever seen
is Vampire Diaries season 4 when Damon and
>> I want it to be legally codified. I don't care about
settlements. I don't care about any of this. I don't care
>> Sorry. I'm going to I I'm going to be passive aggressive
about that one and just not
can't can't. It's >> Gilmore Girls. Have you seen Gilmore
>> STV you've ever seen? >> Lav is still gold in
Overwatch, by the way. Yeah, she doesn't know how to press
>> Wait, I don't even
to remain in a low tier of any game you ever play if you can't
just use your cool downs when they come up. Okay. You cannot
be good at a game. player. I haven't played Overwatch for like
two years. >> Okay. All right. >> Yeah, Diamond's
respectable.
>> I watched you play Junkrat and you literally never dropped
a mine.
>> Okay. You Okay. When I played Junkrat, I had just started
playing FPS shooters
maybe two months before. >> I had never played a video
game. >> I had literally never played an FPS. >> That's
true. >> Until three years a Yes, it is. >> You've
been playing No, this is Sorry. When did you start playing an
FPS?
>> Three years ago. >> Okay. It was like a year ago.
I was watching you playing Junkrat. Yeah. >> I have not
played I have not played Overwatch for years.
>> Okay. Well, I definitely watched it while I was streaming
and I had a stream and my stream is 2 years old as of like 3
days ago.
>> Yeah. Two That's still again. That's two years ago.
>> Okay. But I don't think you came on stream for like
the first couple months I streamed.
>> I don't know if that's true. But I did not play Overwatch
for very long and it was my first FPS ever.
>> And I'm a I'm literally I'm a diamond Marvel player.
Rivals player. I think >> What are the tiers in Marvel
Rivals? >> Um they're similar to Overwatch. >> Marvel
Rivals competitive tiers
ranking system. No, no, no. Yeah, ranking system. Ranks. Diamond
is No. D. They actually made they made I I knew this was going
to be the case. I looked it up. I knew that they would have made
a cope thing so that diamond you could say you're diamond and
pretend you're okay but actually diamond's like a cop tier that
doesn't really exist. >> Morgan just tipped $5. The corrupted
>> does not lust after love's quidian form. We crave more.
Our erectile dysfunction means we are immune to her machinations.
Well, that was cool. Thank you for the $5. Piers Morgan. >> I'm about
the best video games, but I'm definitely out of out of what was
it? Silver, bronze.
>> Okay. Yeah, right in the middle of it. Let's go. >> Lab.
Who would be the peak content Balders Gate 3 lineup with JSLK?
>> Not playing Balders Gate 3. Get out of >> Me,
JSTLK. Wes, by the way, and
>> it' be fun to play a game with Wes >> and Steven
Benell.
>> Damn. Okay. pre-app
drama over Balders's
>> We have drama over >> Ber did happen. Yeah.
>> Did was I involved in that or do you mean you were involved
in that? >> No, you weren't involved in that. >> Yeah,
I don't remember that.
>> You were not involved in that. All right, I'm going
back to We got to actually get through this, guys. We got to
do it real quick. I just got to see what the what the whole analysis
is >> Yeah. So, he does just say a president. I I clarified
that here, but I will I will disagree with past me a little bit
here because while he does say he just wants to set a precedent,
and I'm saying this to kind of move on with the conversation
cuz it's getting stuck on this. He does say he wants to set a
precedent. The only precedent that would ever impact Sony and
Disney is a legal one. They don't give a what your YouTuber social
precedent norms are. They don't give a like if Ethan is saying
he wants to protect the React community from Sony and Disney,
that requires a legal precedent. your your little gentleman's
agreements don't mean to these massive companies these things
I only care >> uh also not what he was talking about >> legal
precedent
to substantiate that and that's how we started watching some
>> listen I love all of you I'm not going to keep getting
interrupted especially when I'm there's >> he definitely
wanted to set a legal precedent and that's what we were talking
about and that's why he put in his legal case that it's about
intentionally siphoning views but you do say that way out of
this conversation now just I'm opting out you anymore I'll be
moderating
>> Okay, cool. So, for the legal precedent thing, if you
could find that clip and stuff like that, that would be really
important because as far as I am aware and based on everything
that I >> it wasn't important. >> I saw leading up
to it and I only had saw it for like the first >> the I
want to say like two months that this was going on, but as far
as I saw his it seemed like all of his posture was, yeah, we're
going to go through with this court case that we these people
can't do this, but if they settle, but if they apologize, but
if >> Queman just does blood sports. I do like doing blood
sports. Yeah, that's true. What's the problem with that? Even
even in Blood Sport, they still argued about the topic. You know,
you still argue about the topic. It's just actually entertaining.
It's just not like the most boring dry [__] ever.
>> You do these things then. Yeah, that will be
that was consistent. Please just
he wanted either a social or legal. >> What was he even
saying for that whole [__] Does he even know what
he was saying for that whole time before I interrupted that?
I truly
>> uh he was saying that he believed that Ethan Klein was
saying you guys just need to apologize or settle or something
which I think is like an insane reason like that would be an
insane if Ethan did that. I would love a clip of that cuz that
sounds completely insane. You sue people on the the premise that
they will settle with you instead of actually fighting you in
court. If you're not ready to fight in court or you don't want
to fight in court or you think it would be harmful to fight in
court, don't sue somebody. That's like an insane thing to say.
It like blows my mind, but really the apps are so long.
>> What did he want? >> Who did Lav actually made
in Overwatch? The respawn screen. The cyber sector. God damn.
>> He wanted individuals to stop maliciously taking content.
>> But you already said that he didn't do it to all people
that maliciously take content. Just people that he couldn't have
a dialogue. >> Wait, do you play what role do you play
in Overwatch or sorry, Marvel Rivals >> I I like playing
Scarlet Witch. I like playing Cloak and Dagger.
Um, and I ju I rogue just came out. I like playing rogue so far.
I'm sort of all over the place.
>> Scarlet Witch is
>> like the Moira sort of. She's like the Moira character.
>> Okay. All right. >> Which would be like DPS.
>> Auto aim heroes. KW. Yeah, I'm My aim is awful, but
I have good game sense. >> There's a team up ability that
works in conjunction with Doctor Strange. Wow, what a cool game.
dialogue with
>> Okay. Where did he say that? >> Where did he say
what? What a part of that rational that if you have a dialogue
with him, you're exempt. >> No, I'm just inferring based
on just projecting that onto him. >> Okay. Where did he
say what? Where did he say he has no intent
any kind of
play the game? Play the game. Where did he say that he has literally
no intent to do any kind of president whatsoever and it's entirely
out of sight? >> Well, no. What I'm suggest I'm saying
to you, is that >> Wait, so he didn't say that. So you're
>> I I haven't I have not made any argument yet. There's
no no argument has been made yet.
All I've said is you were just inserting a motivation for which
there has not been any evidence presented. No argument made.
>> Why the constant interrupting?
Um, hold on. I think there's this thing where people are like,
I can't believe you would interrupt. I think if you are if you
are like totally ranting on a point you feel
is correct and somebody hears like a major disagreement point
that they don't want you to continue with until you've able to
until you're able to hammer something out. I don't think it's
bad for them to go like hey could I just make a quick hey could
I just you don't have to like it but I don't think it's crazy.
Um, I don't think the interrupting is at this point. I don't
think the interruptions were like totally unbounded, but I think
I had interrupted Ry a couple times and he was frustrated by
it. So, he was probably sort of getting annoyed with me and having
interrupted him a couple times cuz I think up to this point he'd
already asked me to stop interrupting him multiple times
>> or something. So, so what I'm saying to So, what I'm
saying to you >> is that you think it's crazy to suggest
that Ethan might look ahead and think, "Oh, should I sue Asmin
Golden XQC or should I sue Hassan's orbiters? Which one's going
to make me win in the public eye?" You think that's crazy to
suggest, but you're crazy to suggest. >> Right as I came
in, you were saying you you were scoffing at Erin and saying
you don't think Ethan thinks that far ahead. >> All of
those various steps that she listed out. Yeah. No, I don't believe
I think >> they're referring to the same thing. figure
out. I'm sorry the big words confusing you. All she's saying
is that Ethan knows there will be public support for going after
Hassan's orbits and not for XGC and as God. >> Yeah. No,
I don't believe this. I don't believe that's what can figure
that out. And to be No, to be clear, you said that I needed him
verbally saying what I was raising. I was >> So you were
just making [__] up. You were literally just throwing
[__] up. >> You seem to be lost. >> Okay.
So you were making up. That's what you were doing. Just say you
were making [__] up. That's fine. >> I I brought
an argument to you. I said something so I could >> I'll
throw the argument back at you. Where did Ethan say that he has
no intent for illegal or social precedent? He only wanted SP.
Where did you say
>> I haven't even said that yet. >> I got to be honest.
The most boring conversation I've ever listened to.
>> Yeah. Well, you don't have any of the facts or understanding
involved. Sorry. I probably should do different content when
you're here. This is my bad. But I do want to finish it real
quick. So, do you mind >> Do you care about this? Do you
care about this? >> Uh chat's definitely involved in this.
Chat enjoyed this when it happened. Chad definitely wants to
watch this. So, I'm trying to watch it through.
>> I would say if you don't have direct statements, you
need other evidence. So, >> I have not pitched the motivation.
I have not pitched the motivation. My argument yet is not anything
about motivation. What Ethan's motivations? I'm just attacking
Rey's substantiation for his argument and he's like, how are
you substantiating that? So, I I'm not I don't need to substantiate
anything >> that he wanted to Yeah. So what is your other
evidence for suggesting that he wants to only discuss this with
reasonable people >> and then queen what is your evidence
for
>> Well I would like to >> I think I'm going to start
like probably like perma banning people who say
um this content again. Oh it's hour 10 of this. Shut up. Literally
>> Oh well you're trying to control your >> Close
the tab. Literally close the tab. >> You're trying to control
your opposition. Your
>> Uh-huh. Using your power against a chatter, someone
with less power than you. You're okay. That's a great gotcha
for the previous argument. Well done.
>> Out. Yeah. So why why do you believe he's only >> He's
running a cult. Yeah. Uh definitely nobody's ever been banned
from Queenage Chat for being annoying. That's never happened
before. True. We're totally running a cult here. >> Getting
people who he can talk to. Oh, people who he can't talk to. Sorry.
>> Well, I don't believe that's the exclusive thing. I
think he's targeting malicious actors. >> You believe that
is the explanatory fact why he didn't go after. That's what you
said. I'm responding. Are you going to let me speak or address
that? >> The worst. >> We got to We got to stop the
interruptions, bro. I'm in the middle of I literally had two
words going off
I promise I'm capable. I think we can inter
goes. I don't think it's like totally disrupt.
>> Okay. Just just focus on that. >> I I see where
this is at. Okay. >> Dude, he's such a It's so crazy. It's
like womanly. Oh, I see what we're doing. I see what you're doing.
Oh, I see what we're doing. Oh, I see what >> has to do
with the voice.
I think if I'm going to be totally calm about this, I think Really
is heated, different temperature than Quimman. Queen didn't come
in that hot. He came in, he's trying to calmly make his points.
I got the impression after a little bit that I came in hotter
than he did. That he was like a little rder, a little more rude
than I expected,
but no, I think he came in, he's like fine. Really is at a different
place in the conversation, though. So, >> it's doing Oh,
you're doing that to me. Good for me to keep track of that and
say, "Hey, I've just been arguing like pretty aggressively with
Rei for like an hour, an hour and a half. You uh like you guys
are at different places, so he's like mad at me. He's annoyed
with me, but you're coming in doing this." And and he's even
more upset.
>> Right now,
>> what's up? >> Wait. TMZ reports that Rob Riner
and his wife Michelle Ryder are the
Okay, so just to be clear, all right, uh I believe that he is
targeting people that he feels are maliciously stealing his content
that he is incapable of having some kind of mutually respectful
dialogue or some kind of uh conversation or he can hold them
to account in some
So, I really was annoyed that I said myself that I don't want
to like cut in on this argument cuz it's like
the proof that I can have a dialogue with you is that you sat
down in the dialogue, told me to go myself with my fully reasonable
positions, refused to engage logically logically with me in any
way. >> I see it now. Gman is just like Herodite in Argent.
>> Thank you. We'll look into Rob Reiner getting stabbed
to death apparently um >> with his wife.
Yeah, crazy stuff. So,
oh, it's so frustrating to me this
was so frustrating.
The proof that you can have a dialogue with this guy is that
he took what you said
and then he said you were he didn't engage with you at all. So,
the point of the conversation was rendered entirely moot. He
basically, this is the level of respect he had for your opinion.
He did the worm and then he went with the video in question that
you're suing people over. He actually did the exact same thing
you said, proved malicious intent to siphon views to you on your
video and like explicitly didn't react and like laughed in your
face and then you watched the clip of him not reacting and laughing
about not reacting. You're like, "Haha, good one, XQC." Like
he bit you in every way, but it was proof he could have a conversation.
I would say it's proof that any conversation with him is pointless.
I think that's what most people would say. >> Queman's
in chat. We need to talk about the elephant in the room. Queer.
>> Okay. So, I don't believe that's the
>> You asked me for my >> I got to I got to finish
watching this really quickly and then we can go into whatever
you want. Okay, Lav, the world is your oyster. >> Oh my
god. Your your little audience told you they didn't care about
this. >> One person told you they didn't care. Your one
person told you they didn't >> At least six people. >> I'm
just going to remind you that this is actually not a democracy.
>> Oh, I'm going to I actually do pull Hold on. I actually
do poll it in chat just so I can show people that I don't give
a [__] Hold on. Slashpoll.
Hold on. Uh, finish this content.
Yes. No. And I'm going to advise everybody to vote for no. Okay.
I want you all to vote for no so I can really drive home how
little I give a about what any of you think about what content
I should be doing. Okay.
The poll. Is the poll not working? The poll's like not going.
I'm not seeing the poll filling up at all. >> It's filling
up.
>> Oh, is it working now, >> guys? If you vote no,
I'll leave the stream and never come back. >> Everything's
broken. Oh, people are voting yes. So, I'm lucky. >> No,
I'm I'm You said the same thing twice. I said mutually respectful
dialogue with or some kind of productive conversation. Those
are the same thing.
>> I said you could they could move
>> I'll donate 100 kicks if you kick lav and just play
civ. Uh, in what universe would that be a good idea? Are you
serious? In what universe would I say, you know what? I'm not
going to take any more donations. I'm not going to do anything.
I'm going to kick out like 80% of my viewers for $1. He just
offered me $1
to make the stream way less entertaining for everybody.
Get the out of here. Like he did. He said mutually respectful
dialogue or productive
Those that's the same thing. You're say you're conveying the
same message twice. That's what you're doing. You just took like
an extra six words to say it because you just want to keep yapping
and sound like you know what you're >> that's really really
easy to do by the way. That's okay. I agree. Really was heated
with Que before Que was really being an
maybe mix of being heated from the previous conversation and
the fact that Queen's usually an but this is the laziest argument
you only make way after the fact like as a reactor. You're like
oh listen he said the same thing twice. Yeah, people who debate
in real time definitely like fill time, fill out so they're not
going to get interrupted. That's 100% what he's doing. But it's
not really that weird. Everyone does >> about It's so funny
when he accuses me at one point of doing like an ego thing with
him. Really is all ego when he's in conversations, man. It is
all ego. It's just like how do I sound smart? He's not trying
to talk about the issue. It's just he just wants to do the like
um well when I grab my active you see you see why when I grab
my active looking looking at this whole situation when I filter
it through I can see that there are two possible outcomes where
he just wants to do that for [__] 6 hours you sway
him social
>> wait wait you you care about Hassan's dog getting shocked
but you wouldn't the dog um are you sure that you have your axioms
grounded right now is this real is this real chat is this real
is this real
just did he actually just do that there's no way >> through
social what I'm saying to you is that there is no evidence of
that because he has not attempted to have a conversation with
Denims, Casey Trron, or Froen about copyright at any point. So
why would we believe that that is the fact that it is making
the difference? >> Well, didn't he literally have a dialogue
with Casey Tron to be able to get the settlement? >> We're
talking about the decision to sue Rally. That's the whole conversation.
>> At the point of a sword, he extracted a >> right
now. >> W dialogue
time. >> Yeah. prior to the suit. No, he he obviously sued,
but then he had a dialogue with her that resulted in him dropping
the suit. So, that would infer the question, hold on. That would
that would be that would that would show that if this individual
is willing to be able to have a dialogue with him to be able
to be like, "Hey, you know what? Uh, X, Y, and Z concession.
Yeah, they would be able to they would be able to drop the lawsuit.
They would settle." >> That was very disrespectful of me
there. That was very disrespectful of me to make those noises
while he was talking. >> We have in the law real quick.
We have in the lawsuit itself, this lawsuit is about ending the
practice of lazy reaction videos that copy the entire copyrighted
works and purposely siphon views and revenue away from the original.
So that is what the president >> literally the first line.
>> Okay. Okay. So so really
points in any direction but
this cannot be the explanatory factor for why he sued Casey Tron
Rogan and Denims and not as from Golden XQC. Right. You must
you must agree with that. >> Sorry. Say again. You're using
you're using an example after the lawsuit has already been filed
to demonstrate Ethan's reasoning for why he delineated between
different targets in the filing of the lawsuit. You're
>> it's not so it's not just that the delineating of who
he would prior prior. All I would need to do is say that he didn't
believe that he could have a reasonable dialogue with uh what's
her face prior. >> Did he attempt to >> I don't know.
>> He says no. >> Well, do you know that for sure?
Do you know that none of it her >> unless they're all dude?
You hear?
>> Ah, I just feel like it's so obvious that you can't
have a productive dialogue with XQC. >> Do you hear that
right? >> Like that dialogue was the opposite of it's literally
memed for being the least productive dialogue of all time. >> I
say the answer is no
because there is >> like like hypothetically with everybody
you could have a productive dialogue except XQC where you know
for a fact you cannot have a productive dialogue. Like you've
literally tried the dialogue and it had the least productive
outcome possible, which was him saying, "I don't care about your
arguments. Go [__] yourself. I have your whole house
on my wrist. Also, here's the worm."
No evidence that that has happened. So, we all assume, right?
If you don't have evidence for an event occurring, and there's
never been any suggestion that event occurred, there's never,
literally, this has never come up. all the litigation. There
has never ever ever been any mention of an attempt to reach out
and have a conversation about copyright. There has never
did Ethan reach out. My answer is no. That didn't happen. >> Did
you just make up a whole bunch of things to say no? No, no, that
did. Come on, man. >> Now, how does Really betray
this is this is cheap, Queman. Okay, you should know this is
cheap. You're like literally giving your fully fleshed out after
the fact post hawk rationale for for how you see this going so
that people can see you're correct. That's cheap, man. >> What
I said, let's hear what I say here. Let's hear exactly what I
say. Let's hear what what I say here and what says afterwards.
Okay. >> I feel like I feel like I'm watching this and
I'm like, "Oh, I can't believe he pre-swept like this for himself."
>> I don't know. >> The answer is no. >> Well,
do you know that for sure? Do you know that none of it?
So, I say the answer is no. And he says, "You know that for sure."
And I say immediately unless there is some secret piece of evmmed
Immediately. There's my next line. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. You
made >> I'm with Really. I think we would wait to see if
this thing he made up in his head actually happened. >> So
true. Thank you for the $5. Do you know that none of the H3 staff,
nobody attempted to reason with Casey Tron at all? Because I
know while they're declining. Okay. So, so okay. Well, you just
made a claim without evidence. You said no. They did not reach
out. That is a definitive
nervous happened. >> Okay. So, hold on. >> It's a
negative
evidence
didn't happen. quite embarrassing, right? I I start >> No,
no, you're saying something.
>> I do think Quinn is being relatively reasonable here
though that he he did follow up with um like a clarification
shortly after >> definitively did not say >> no.
There's no way. So there is So you are saying something definitively
did not happen because there is no evidence at all pointing in
either direction >> because because I said the answer is
no. We said no.
>> No, there's no
>> No, you said that it did. I probably needed to cool
this down uh from where I had it when I was arguing with our
relevant like as the host of the channel, as the host of the
stream. I this is probably a failing on my part that like I needed
to calm this down and just say like, "Hey, we just having a really
contentious conversation. Don't want you to transfer on to this
other guy, even though he's like actually an
good point in the entire two to three hours." Um yeah, because
he was there to like check assumptions and stuff. I
I I wouldn't say he made no good points. I'm sure he ran like
some basic logic was like helpful in some ways. I just think
probably his his standard bias would be in favor of Ethan Klein.
And so I I don't find it particularly useful most of the time
if like I'm like here's my evidence like take and then somebody's
like, "Well, hypothetically, couldn't something else be true?"
And it's like, "Okay, what is that based on?" Well, I don't know.
I haven't really looked into it. Like, well, that feels frustrating.
That feels frustrating when that happens.
Yeah.
name one good point he made. I'm sure if I went through this
I could find like a dozen good points he made. I just get particularly
frustrated with um basically it's like the idea of like you have
somebody with a a bias in favor of someone you're like I have
a criticism of them and they're like well I think they're kind
of a good guy. Oh that's >> Oh no. >> Anyway, okay.
Rob Reiner. Did Rob Reiner get stabbed? >> Yeah. And people
think it's his son. >> Oh no.
>> Yeah. who struggled for years with severe heroin and
hard drug addiction, cycling in and out of 18 different rehab
and experiencing periods of >> Rob Reiner and wife Michelle
found dead at LA home. Wounds consistent with a knife.
God knife attacks in America. What's the world coming to?
Rob Reiner, the legendary director and wife Michelle Singer Riner
have died, TMZ has learned. As we told you, two dead bodies were
found in Rob and Michelle's Brentwood home Sunday afternoon.
and law enforcement sources tell us it is the Riners. Our sources
say that the two suffered lacerations consistent with the knife.
The LAPD's robbery homicide division is still investigating.
Dispatch audio captures a firefighter calling for backup to the
Brentwood mansion around 3:30 p.m. Though it doesn't provide
any further information about the circumstances in the abode.
Rob, the son of famed comedian Carl Reiner, who passed away in
the 2000s or in 2020, sorry, started his career in show business
as a comedy writer in the 1960s, working as Steve Martin's writing
partner on the Smother Smother's Brothers Comedy Hour in ' 68
and ' 69.
Um, he wrote a writer, All in the Family, something he was involved
with. Uh, focused more on directing with that. Oh, he did this
is Spinal Tap. I didn't know he did that. It's kind of
>> Oh, he directed The Princess Bride. Oh, that's a great
movie. >> That's how I know.
>> Uh, Auto Cavalry, you're gone for a week. Uh, come back
when you don't say super weird like that. Jesus Christ.
>> Uh, he said another down.
>> very weird. Actually, on second thought, we just don't
need it. There we go. Boom. All right, back to this. Michelle,
and Rob had three kids together, Jake, Nick, and Romy. I haven't
seen anything about the the sun yet. But where you seeing that?
You seeing on Twitter? Where are we seeing that? Where you seeing
that? Where you seeing that, Lav? Where you seeing that,
>> Lav? Where you seeing that, Lav? Lav
lab >> on Twitter.
>> Link. Link. Link. Any links? >> Oh, I'm already
a a billion posts down.
>> Rob Reer, >> this makes me too sad. I don't like
to talk about death. I might go.
>> Oh, this make me too sad.
It's too sad. >> I just want to say he looks so old and
it just makes me sad.
>> That sucks >> thinking about it. >> Other
son Nick who is now missing after the fatal stabbing to Brentwood
home.
She brought the topic up demanded we talk about and is like actually
I'm so sad I got to go. That's crazy